[Music]
what I think is remarkable you know the
time that we've been having this
conversation if you trace the beginning
of the current conversation to 2014
maybe 22 Ferguson or to Eric Gardner
right how much the technology has
developed now the tools are now there in
ways that they are not we it's easy to
forget that just two years ago when
Ferguson was happening there was no live
video capacity the same way there were
live streamers who were out there but
there was no periscope or meerkat there
was no Facebook live there wasn't even
Twitter video yet nor did upload video
people had to use vine or Instagram
right and so what this allows is the
same way that all social media creates
kind of a more democratic media process
people in real time can share their own
stories live video allows us physical
access to things that we never would
have had otherwise I mean the video that
you know diamond Reynolds takes of her
boyfriend foligno Castillo after he shot
changes the world changes our perception
of the shooting starts what ends up
being one of the the flash points around
these issues where we go from beginning
with Alton sterling than folinic with
steel and then to dallas and and without
that video it's very unlikely that
officer would have been charged as he
has been now and it's unlikely we would
even know the name philander castillo
and so that tool that ability for her in
two taps of her phone to start sharing
with the world the moment she was in I
is like I said it just has the capacity
to change the world it was that video
was just so remarkable in that it was
traumatic as you watched it you felt
like you were physically there I'm in
the car someone just been shot by the
police that was different than the
feeling of the Eric Gardner video even
though Walter Scott video in part if
only because we knew it had been live
and I think that that was just a you
know I said it was just a turning point
I think in the way video is as
manifested and has played a role in
these cases the major question and that
lies at the heart of our inability to
deal with and to actually create changes
to a system
that would lead to the decrease in faith
use of fatal force is our refusal to
believe black and brown people welcome
brown people have been saying for
generations that this was the case they
were being beat up there being they were
being pulled over you were there getting
arrested on fraudulent charges and we
essentially for generations that we
don't believe you we we've had case
after case for decades for years of
people who are unarmed or who were shot
in the back who there was a weapon
perhaps planted and we the media and we
are as a society just did not believe
these people what video hasn't done is
it exposed the level to which our
refusal to validate the stories of
people of color and people who are
telling us about this trauma they're
going through the extent to which that
has masked in justices that now that we
can see this with our own eyes we can
see that some of these shootings should
not be happening and that someone should
be held accountable for some of them and
so yes I think it's just a window into a
world that has always existed these
videos are forcing us to look at things
we otherwise don't want to see but i
think that out of discomfort potentially
comes change right that we have for
generations willfully ignored this we
don't want to talk about this we don't
talk about police reform we don't want
to believe that that dead man perhaps
didn't deserve to be killed we want our
police shootings or killings are police
officers we want them to fit into a
tight little narrative we want to be
able to put a bow on them and say well
police shoot bad guys and that's what
happens and we want to absolve ourselves
emotionally of having to think about it
anymore and I think that what video does
is it complicates that narrative it
complicates this good guy bad guy
narrative right we teach our kids to
play cops and robbers right then that
these interactions of the police are on
this binary or either you have a copy of
the robber the cop is always the good
guy and the robber is always the bad guy
and I think that what we've seen brought
to light via this protest movement in
via this moment where we're talking
about policing with this nuance in this
level is if that is not in fact how it
always works and then you have police
shootings of people perhaps even who
were the bad guy who had committed a
crime but that does not erase the
question
okay but should this person be dead and
there's a nuance their right and I think
that again that's a new ones that were
uncomfortable with we're very often
uncomfortable questioning that type of
Police Authority because because it
raises these real questions about what
is the role of the government and the
police in our lives and who should be
dead and who should not be but but I
think that you know I definitely think
video it beautifully complicates that
and forces us to grapple with what might
actually lead to different outcomes
right and I think that that's kind of
the point of what a lot of the activism
[Music]